depuis quelques jours le torchon brûle
entre Philippe cavrivière et Damien Abad
le point de départ de cette histoire des
blagues lancées par l'humoriste Damien a
souvent la même démarche de ses
sympathiques oiseaux noir et blanc des
contrées froides des blagues qui ont
vivement fait réagir l'ancien ministre
des Solidarités atteints une maladie
entraînant des déformations physiques et
des raideurs articulaires je ne peux pas
tolérer que l'on s'en prenne à mon
physique
d'une grade
é des excuses Philippe cavrivière sont
des fois de plus pris à l'homme
politique samedi soir sur France 2
si tu peux et ce matin sur RTL Philippe
cavrivière a réitéré j'ai dit qu'il
avait une démarche de pingouin alors
j'aimerais m'excuser clairement auprès
de tous les paris j'écoute l'être
ouverte de l'ancien ministre Damien
abattre contre Philippe cabri d'hier
peut-on rire des handicapés
alors
les chéris tiens Raymond toi tu toi tu
acceptes pas alors moi
Philippe c'est vraiment un pote et après
moi je suis moi j'adore ce qui fait
quand je le vois chez la Salamé quand je
l'écoute sur RTL j'adore son humour
j'adore ce qu'il fait mais je trouve
c'est très compliqué de s'attaquer à une
personne handicapée parce que elle peut
pas se défendre et c'est un truc quoi
c'est une souffrance bah c'est compliqué
de se défendre tous les jours la le même
sketch parce que le mec il a il a du mal
à marcher je trouve ça très compliqué
mais toutes sortes de handicap là en
l'occurrence c'est quelqu'un qui a du
mal à marcher demain ça va être
quelqu'un qui est sur un fauteuil
roulant après demain mais ça part pas là
alors je vais vous dire je vais vous
dire un truc et j'ai eu la chance de
lancer
exactement c'est vraiment c'est la
première chose
ils sont les premiers à ce manuel et au
contraire si tu lis vannes pas et ben
ils sont ils se sont différents alors
qu'ils sont pas différents
quand ils viennent ici pour se faire
vaner sur du divertissement pour rigoler
ils en sont conscients ils en sont
d'accord le ministre il est pas d'accord
parfois vous avez des gens qui se font
vanner dans la vie dans la vie en
société de tous les jours ils sont pas
d'accord pour être Valais moi si tu vas
me Valais je vais aller voir un moment
donné je vais te dire STOP quand
Benjamin le mec là les gens qu'on a ils
viennent s'amuser dans une amie oui mais
en fait j'allais prendre la parole et tu
l'as vu sur moi aussi c'est relou aussi
tu vois
c'est quoi cette ambiance là haut ouais
les gens viennent dans Touche pas à mon
poste ils viennent aussi s'amuser c'est
ça le truc donc ils sont là ils prennent
au second degré là le monsieur il a
jamais demandé à ce qu'on s'amuse de son
fils comment il le vit on sait pas si on
va revoir parce que on va voir de quoi
ça parle merci de commencer le 5 janvier
dernier
quotidienne sur RTL il se moque
ouvertement Damien Abad des accusations
contre lui et de son handicap regardez
le académie des Césars a annoncé que les
nommés mise en examen pour violence
notamment sexuelle ne pourront pas plus
d'ailleurs
oui le théâtre du Châtelet risque d'être
un peu vide ça va nous rappeler le covid
cette année les Césars sont très
attendus
César de la révélation masculine les
nommés sont Damien bad dans l'étonnant
le moignon la jupe et la plaignante
[Musique]
c'est même un peu facile et ça concerne
une personne s'acharner sur son handicap
moi ça me mais ça me fait un peu mal
parce que c'est Jean-Marie
souvent dans des hôpitaux j'étais au
contact de beaucoup de personnes de
gamins handicapés qui se moquent entre
eux handicap et tout ça est formidable
non il faut surtout pas leur retirer ça
tu vois mais là c'est une attaque perso
sur un mec et sur ces handicaps
physiques je trouve que c'est pas drôle
alors sachez que Damien Abad a exigé des
excuses et Philippe cavrivière insiste
dans sa chronique sur quelle époque il a
refait une petite allusion au député
révélation
masculine les nommés sont
Michel au petit pour son rôle dans des
hommes et des zboub
Patrick Poivre d'Arvor dans Buzz
l'éclair
bad mon copain
attrape un peu
alors et ce matin sur RTL il est attaqué
encore Damien Abad en revenant sur la
demande d'excuse et là il a été encore
plus loin
en effet demandé des excuses publiques
effectivement j'ai dit qu'il avait une
démarche de pingouin alors j'aimerais
m'excuser platement auprès de tous les
pagnes qui nous écoutent car aucun
pingouin n'a été accusé l'agression
sexuelle à ma connaissance la meilleure
réponse à Damien Abad ne vient pas de
moi mais de Philippe Croizon qui s'y
connaît en handicap et ceinture noire
d'invalidité Philippe a un 3 étoiles au
Guide moignon niveau handicap personne
ne lui arrive à la cheville qu'il n'a
plus Philippe Crozon a répondu à la
demande d'excuse de Damien belle
tentative d'abat de buzz voilà cours
mais efficace comme Philippe Croizon et
pour conclure sur Damien Abad au vu des
soupçons répétées de comportement
inappropriés avec les femmes son
problème n'est pas ses membres Invalides
c'est bien son membre trop valide à
bonne entendeur salut
[Musique]
alors ça rigole
toi Gilles pour moi c'est drôle ça c'est
le premier critère deuxièmement c'est du
second degré c'est la tradition
française de l'humour politique je vois
pas pourquoi on peut s'en émouvoir oui
on peut rire du handicap à partir du
moment où on en fait un skate ça ne vise
pas la personne ça vise peut-être
l'ancien ministre ou moi ça ne me gêne
pas du tout très franchement et Damien
Abad a tout à fait les moyens de
répliquer donc je trouve que c'est du
très bon humour oui moi j'ai eu Philippe
Keria cet après-midi il m'a dit qu'il a
longtemps hésité avant de faire des
blagues sur les personnes handicapées
avec elle et il m'explique que faire des
vannes sur les handicapés c'est une
manière de dépasser l'handicap mais bien
sûr
on exclut ces personnes en revanche là
où je pense que Damien Bade n'est pas
très honnête c'est ce qui énerve c'est
pas tant la vanne sur le handicap c'est
ce à quoi illusion qui se sert de ça
pour se miser et et je pense que c'est
pas la balançoire
j'ai eu la chance de remplace de vous
remplacer dans ouvert à tous et c'est
vrai que tous les handicapés ont comme
les autres donc il faut
quand je dis ça c'est que c'est ce qui
me disent on veut paraître comme eux
parce qu'effectivement il y a un
handicap effectivement la blague et la
vanne ils ont envie qu'on les vanille et
ils ont dit qu'on blague avec eux mais
c'est vrai Cyril Amel après je voudrais
Véronique et Kelly moi je trouve pas ça
drôle franchement
on rigole pas du handicap ce qu'il a
fait ce qu'il a accusé la cuisine certes
mais non c'est humilier moi je trouve la
démarche de pingouin ça c'est trop
franchement c'est humiliant il faut être
handicapé pour se rendre compte que
c'est pas c'est pas drôle c'est pas
facile et non l'attaquer sur ça moi je
trouve ça dégueulasse
avec le fait qu'on rigole avec eux que
eux ils rigolent entre eux comme tu l'as
dit Jean-Marie et le fait de rigoler
dans leur dos sans qu'il puisse répondre
moi je trouve ça vraiment nul je trouve
pas ça drôle c'est nul alors c'est moi
Philippe je trouve toujours drôle en
fait le problème c'est que là tout le
monde sur le plateau comme Gilles tout à
l'heure après
que tu puisses parler à leur place en
fait
il y a des personnes en situation
je vais vous dire moi mon avis alors je
disais justement équilibre pardon ce que
tu viens de dire important et ça et ça
traduit tout justement tu dis tu es pas
handicapé donc tu peux pas en rire on
est dans le drame de cette société thé
noir tuerie des Noirs TPD tu ris des
[ __ ] tu es musulman pur et des
musulmans tes juifs et handicapés
rapport c'est que justement je suis très
drôle est-ce que j'aime justement c'est
qu'on puisse se moquer de communauté de
handicap pourquoi comme bâti pardon
mademoiselle c'est ce qu'on faisait
avant est-ce que tu es très drôle et
maintenant il y a que Cyril qui peut
faire une blague sur le Maghreb il y a
que moi qui peut faire une blague sur
les homosexuels et ça et c'est ça le
drame de cette société et les humoristes
qui essaient
Véronique tu es d'accord avec Mathieu
mais moi en fait ce que j'ai pas entendu
le truc sur le moignon je trouve qu'on
peut on peut rire de tout moi je pense
vraiment
que tout à coup on parle des moyens oui
c'est ça me gêne mais moi j'avais par
exemple le sketch du Pingouin
excusez-moi mais moi pour moi c'est j'ai
pas une seconde pensée handicap et je
connaîtrais pas à date j'aurais pas
pensé au handicap le pingouin c'est une
vieille blague qu'on fait quand elle
laisse le pantalon et ça donc plus une
référence à à ce qu'il a fait
sexuellement en tous les cas ce dont il
est accusé et il y a présomption
d'innocence donc le pantalon qui se
baisse quand on a après ça donne une
démarche de pingouin et pour moi c'est
plus une référence à ça donc j'ai pas vu
le truc et après le truc moi si tu peux
oui effectivement ça peut faire
référence un peu à son handicap mais à
ce moment ça fait aussi référence au
truc du harcèlement donc j'avais pas vu
de moquerie qui soit absolument voilà en
ce qui s'en sert beaucoup aussi le
ministre enfin qui n'est plus ministre
d'ailleurs
pour l'instant il y a la présomption
d'innocence et en tout cas moi de ce que
je sais coller lui c'est un garçon à
chaque fois qui a été un amour
voilà et après on attend que la justice
fasse son travail mais voilà et Philippe
pour moi c'est en ce moment le plus
drôle à la télévision je suis désolé
voilà donc c'est le plus drôle à la télé
moi je suis d'abord complet à la radio
avec Matthieu Veronique je trouve que
c'est voilà mais exceptionnel il est
noir en plus il est méchant c'est un
super mec très important
on devrait avoir une sorte d'humour un
peu soft un peu light un peu adapté un
peu comme ça en descendant un peu
mielleux mais c'est ça l'irrespect en
fait ça veut dire qu'on traite pas ces
gens là comme les autres moi j'ai une
maman qui est handicapée elle adore
qu'on se fout de sa gueule elle trouve
que c'est la moindre des élégants la
moindre des politesses Philippe Croizon
par exemple
hier on le remerciant de se [ __ ] de la
gueule des personnes handicapées en
disant et ben écoutez moi je suis amputé
des quatre membres mais je suis pas
amputé de l'humour tu es au courant
pareil il a remercié Philippe Gabriel de
le traiter comme une personne aussi
normale donc je pense qu'il a raison et
je pense que cloisonné comme l'a dit
très justement Mathieu suivant l'humour
suivant sa communauté sa religion c'est
c'est comment dire c'est ta sexualité
c'est juste insupportable mais à partir
du moment franchement
il faut quand même le relevé alors et
donc un moment quand ça vexe
là c'est de la charnemment en plus je
veux dire une fois deux fois trois fois
quatre fois il est pas trop sur ça il
peut être drôle sur autre chose il y a
pas de souci
il y a des handicapés peut-être qu'ils
aiment qu'on rigole de ça il y en a qui
n'aime pas à partir du moment il y en a
qui aime pas on fait pas voilà stop
exceptionnel après après je comprends
aussi Amel qui dit qu'à un moment il y
en a qui pense comme elle aussi et je
trouve que c'est bien qu'elle défende
aussi ça
depuis 20 ans
c'est comme la dernière fois mon chéri
noir avec un peu
meilleur ami
il adore qu'on se fout de sa gueule
non mais c'est ça non mais n'importe
quoi Philippe de toute façon on sait
c'est drôle moi je vous dis c'est le
plus drôle en ce moment voilà mais après
il y a pas plus drôle je l'aime il le
sait on va voir ce qu'on pense
à 41 % vous voyez bon c'est oui mais
c'est plutôt équilibre